よろしくお願いします
物質の話はちょっと長くなりましたけど
今日はまた大変考えていただきたい大事なポイントなんです
で これはルーパーサモッターナナヤと言って
パーリ語でこの二十六番目百八十六ページにルーパーサモッターナナヤという言葉ありまして
どのように色が生まれますかという現れますかということなんですね
だから そこで色というのは物質で
物質が四つの原因で生まれますということは
この四つの原因とか説明したと思います
で その四つはこのカンマチッタウトゥアーハラという四つなんですね
カンマは業で 業から色が生まれると
チッタっていうのは心
心からまた物質が生まれると
ウトゥっていうのはこの物質的な法則なんですね
いわゆる天気やら環境やらいろんなもの
そういうものから色が生まれますよと
アーハラっていうのは
この まあ普通に言えば食べ物なんですけど
まあこの場合は他のところからエネルギーをいただいて
自分の物質を新しく作るという四つの方法
それで今日はこのカンマサモッターナルーパという
この業からどんな色が生まれますかと
カルマから
まあクッチタトラカーマーワジランルーパワジランチェーピパンチャヴィーサディダンピクサラクサラカンマンアビサンカタンアッジャッティカサンターネカンマサ
モッターナルーパンパティサンディンウパーダーヤッハネーカネーサモッッターペーテ
ィという言葉 で ここで
あの あの ちょっとあの
まだ心の世界は説明してないんだから
このここら辺からはちょっとわからないかもしれません
ですから 私はできるだけ説明は省きますが
ここでこのどんな式が生まれるかと僕は前に言ったんだけど
それはちょっと間違いで
どんな心から どういうどういう心から物質が生まれますかということを言ってるんですね
で カンマだから 業だから
我々はこのいろんなことを毎日喋ったり
考えたり 体行動したりしているんですね
そういうものは この何かしたいという意志があるんですね
私たちに 考えたいという意志があるんだから考えてるんです
それで喋りたいという気持ちが生まれるんだから喋ってるんです
手を手を動かしたい 体を動かしたいという意志がありますから
その手体を動かしてるんですね
ですから 意志という言葉は大変大事なんですね
意志はこのパーリ語でチェータナというんです
たまにもしかすると意としても訳しているかもしれませんだけど
このチェータナ このパーリの言葉を覚えておいてください
チェータナ これ英語で言えば Will
Will という言葉があるんです
この このフリーウィルとか
普通英語でよく使っていることは自由意志とかね
人間には自由がありますから
かどうか哲学書もいろいろ考えたりもするんですね
その Will なんですね
そうでないと この I will go とかその Will じゃないんです
我々はなんて言いますか Future
Tense 未来 未来形を表す場合は Will と shall という言葉を二つ使ってますね
英語で その意味でもない
でもその意味で Will shall 使ってますけど
I will go っていうのは
私はこれから行くだろうという
いわゆるまだ行ってないんだけど
行く意志がありますよと
という意味なんですからね
ですから I am willing to go と言えば
私は行きたがってますよと
という意味ですからね
だから心の中のエネルギーなんですね
その英語の Will shall の場合も使っているのは
ですから shall は使わない
shall はちょっと強烈なんですね
意味としては ですから
聖書だったら全部 shall という言葉使ってますね Thou
shalt not kill と
「殺すなかれ」というものすごい命令形で
で  will いれば まあ私は殺さんだろうとという風になってますから
まあ一応自分の意思になってくるんです
まあそういうことで will という言葉使ってますね
ですから この心に常に我々は心で行動しているんです
心で行動しているんだから
常に心に意志があるんです
で 意志がない心はないんです
で 仏教から言えば この意志全くない心っていうのは全く我々ないんです
そこはちょっと考えてほしいんです
だから 例えば寝ていたっても
もう深い睡眠に入っていたっても
我々は心が歩かないかわからないんですね
人間心というのは この表現
何て言いますか この 意識というんですか
この あのコンシャスマインドという
この無意識ではなくて
ただ考えている心に 普通人間というのは意志と心で言うんですね
考えたり いろんなことを頭の中で回転させたりするのは
それは心のちょっと一部の働きだけなんです
まだいろいろ働きいっぱいあるんです
何か考えたりするのは心の一つの働きであって
で 何も他のことを考えて
ぼけーっと何か見ている時も
目で見ているということもやってるんですね
そこらにも意志があるんです
ですから この心がなしに何も行動はできない
私はいつでも言うのは
例えば我々のまぶた閉じることも
指一本動かすことも心でやってるんですね
でも 私は指一本動かしたいとか
そういうふうに頭で考えてはないんです
それは反射的でやってるんですよと言いますけど
それはヨーロッパ的な考え方で
こちらでは反射とかそんなことは言わないで
もう仏教で反射っていうのは
物理学的なものは反射かもしれません
それ以外は別に反射っていうことは使えないし
ですからこの ただ私は喋っていると
例えば手とか足とか動かしているならば
そちらにも自分の心が入って意志で動かしているんです
ですから このよく仏教で言うのは
この心はどんどん整えて整えて落ち着いてくると
このすごい荒っぽい体の行動がどんどん落ち着いてくるんです
自己コントロールできてくると
だから経典でよく出てくるんですね
お釈迦様を見ただけで人々が心きれいになっちゃって
あのお釈迦様を信じるようになって修行に入ったんだと
別に深い難しい説法を聞いたわけじゃなくて
ただ体見ただけでもう心はじーんと見た人の心は落ち着いてしまっちゃうんですね
なぜかというと 無駄な動きは全く全くなし
0 我々にはいっぱい無駄な動きがあるんですね
そこで我々の考える時でも無駄な考え方いっぱいあるんです
それで時間なくなってしまっちゃうんですね
忙しくなっちゃうんですね
だから普通の人は 心を抑えてない人は
心コントロールしてない人は
ものすごい忙しくて慌てて焦って生活しなくちゃいけない
それでもやるべきことはやって終わってない
途中で人生終わってしまっちゃうんです
で 心を整えてくると もうちゃんと
全ては意思で行動していることよくわかってるんだから
意思で行動する ですから
手を動かすにしたっても
ちゃんとそれは意識でちゃんと気づいてやっているんですね
ですから お釈迦様なんか歩く場合は
もうみんなすごくその歩き方に驚いたんですね
ただ僕 普通に歩いたんだけど
で 無駄な動きは全くないんだと
首を振ったり 手を振ったり
あっち見たりこっち見たりとか
歩く時はその行動をずっとやってなぜ無駄な動きがないかというと
心は整えているんだから
そこにだけ意思は入ってるんですね
その行動にだけ ですから
お釈迦様が説法していた時でも
ほんの微かでも手を動かしたりとかはなかったんですね
そういうことで 見ただけでも心は人の心は落ち着いて
悩み苦しみが消えちゃうんだと
ということはあるんです
それで私は今言いたいのは
私たちも同じく意思で行動しているんです
そこで一つ考えながら他のことをやったりするんだから
心は落ち着いてない あっち走ったりこっちへ走ったり
もう走りっぱなしで それで全部無駄なんですね
ほとんど我々がやってる仕事の九十九パーセントは無駄の無駄であって
ちょっと一パーセントぐらいはもう仕事に入っちゃうんですね
例えば文章を書くにしたっても
余計なことはいっぱい考えている
足を動かしている 頭は嗅いだりしたり
いろんなことをやりながらやってますから
肝心な文章を書くということには
ほんのちょっとしか時間使ってないんです
時間の経過から見ると
それは全部時間かかるんです
例えば私は喋る 喋る時はこうやって手を上げたりすると
手を上げる時間は喋ってないんです
そこはあまりにも物質の流れが光の速度と同じ速度でやってますから
わからないだけ 気にしない
気にならない 気にしないではなくて
それだけのこと ちょっと心落ち着いてくるとそれはわかるんですね
で あの そこでどんな心にもそういうことで意思があるというと
これは本当はアビダンマは違うところで説明しなくちゃいけないところですけど
まだそこら辺に行ってないんだから
今日はちょっと余計に余分に説明いたしますが
人間には常に意思があるんです
人間ではなくて 生命には
仏仏教から言えば自分の意思から離れる瞬間はないんです
死ぬ瞬間も意思がちゃんとあるんです
その意思というのは 普通人間もう何時間も考えて考えて
あれやりたい やりたい
やりたいと言って そのような意思ではないんです
それはかなり意思というものは固まって固まって強調して強烈になったところで気づくんです
ああ これ意思だと 例えば喋る時は無意識的に手を動かしたりするんですね
それで手を動かして動かして動かして疲れたところで
自分が手を動かしたんだと気づくだけのことなんですね
でも 瞬間瞬間も意思でそういうことをやってるんです
ですから この普段私たち意思だ
心だと思っているのは
あの純粋な心でも意思でもなく
この心の強烈な塊になったところで気づくんだけである
意思も強烈に固まったら自分に意思があったと
盗む意思があったと 殺す意思があったと
そこで気づくだけで ですから
その差ですね 理解してほしいのは
で 指を動かす時も まぶたを閉じる時も
ちゃんと意思があって
心でそれをやってるんです
それで十回ぐらいまぶたを閉じてみるとわかるでしょ
それを意思でやってるということは
連続して十回ぐらいやっても
それはちゃんと意思でやってるってことはわかるんですね
それをまあ三十秒に一回ぐらいやっても気づかないんです
それだけのこと それで問題は人間に意思が自由かないかということなんですね
じゃあ自由に意思が動くんですかと
例えば私は手を上げたくて手を上げる
それ自由じゃないかと
手を上げる自由があるんじゃないかと
そういうふうにも考えられるんですね
アビダンマを勉強したくてこっち来てるんですね
誰かに行かなかったら殺しますよと脅かしてきたわけじゃないんですね
じゃあ自分の意思で来ているんだと
ですから人間に自由意志あるんだと
というふうには言えますが
それは一部の考え方で
もう一部の人々は 人間には自由意志が全くないんだと
作られたものだから 生かされているものだから
その法則によって生きているだけですと
全く自由意志がないんだという極論もあって
自由意志があるという極論もあって
仏教はまあその場合も中道なんですね
いつでも 自由か自由でないかっていうことは
まああまり問題にしない
なぜならば自由って何ですかと
誰一人も定義してないんですね
自由意志 フリーウィル
フリーって何ですかね？それを定義していないで
定義しておかないで フリーウィルあるかフリーウィルないかと考えるのはものすごくおかしいんです
ですから 哲学で我々が出会う
心理学で出会うこのフリーウィルという概念というのは
根拠なくもうただ考えてるだけのことなんです
フリーって何ですか？と
このフリー自由という概念を考えると
仏教で仏教は定義からいきますから
偶然ということと同じなんですね
アクシデンタル その意味と同じなんですね
偶然 突然 と同じ意味なんです
だから 例えば立ちなさいと言われて
人は立つと で そこで言われたんだから立ったんであって
その人の意思で立ったのではないかというふうな条件を考えちゃうと
で まあそれはちょっと置いておきます
これ アクシデンタルというのは
この前もってこうなるだろうということは知らない
突然現れたと 例えば 人が家の周りにいっぱいゴミを燃やしちゃうと
無造作に そうすると その家も火事になるだろうということはみんな知ってるんですね
そこでうちも火事に気が付いちゃって火事になったと
あ これは偶然やとは誰も言わないんですね
なぜならば それなりの原因があったんだから
それで偶然うちが火事になったという場合は何ですか？と
そういうのは偶然というのはないんですね
結局は それなりの十分因縁が条件が揃ってないと火事にならないんですね
ですから 火事になるべき原因が揃っていたんだから火事になったんです
ただ 水が燃えないんですね
もし水がいきなり燃え始めちゃったら
あのガソリンみたいに
それは偶然と言ってもいいんです
我々はガソリンでも灯油でも燃えるということを知ってますけど
水は燃えない ですから
水でも燃えるならば 偶然という概念は成り立ちます
偶然という出来事はないんです
だけど それで全部決まってるんですか？というと決まってもないんです
なぜかというと 例えば事故に遭ったと
それは偶然だと そうでもないんです
事故に遭う原因は十分揃ったんだから
事故に遭う んであって
じゃあ時候に合う定めでしたかと
そうでもないんです ですから
仏教はこの因縁ですか
ちゃんとした原因があって
条件揃ったところで必然的に結果が出る
それをいつでも言っているんです
ですから 自由か自由がないかということはもう問題にならないんです
自由でもなく 自由はないわけでもないと
なぜ自由でもないと言うんですか？原因全部揃ったところですから
自由とは言えないんですね
原因揃ったらその結果は必然的に出るんです
それは止まることはできないんです
必然的というんですか
必ずしも出るんです 原因揃ったら
ですから自由がない そう言っても確実に起こりますかというと
そうでもないんです その原因揃えないようにすることもできるんですね
いわゆる結果変化させることもできるんです
火事になったうちから燃焼する可能性もあるし
どうせ火事になったら燃焼する
それは途中で止めることもできるんです
そういうことで 因果法則にもから仏教の話は全然離れないんです
そこで意志の話なんですけど
我々もいろんなことをやったりはするんだけど
やっぱりある程度でこのパターンが決まってあって
それはこの因縁法則によってもうそう考えるしか方法ない
例えば私が皆様に悪口を言うと
そうすると必然的に人間の心っていうのは好きなことを聞くようにプログラムしているんですね
好きなことを聞きたいと
自分の心を躍らせてくれるものは聞きたいというプログラムされている
それは躍らせてくれないんだから
それは排除しなくてはいけないんですね
いわゆるもう拒否しなくちゃいけないんですね
この悪口を言われると
で 拒否する その拒否する気持ちっていうのは怒りなんですね
動作なんです ですから
悪口言われたら必ずも怒りが生まれてくる
気持ち悪くなっちゃうんです
機嫌が悪くなっちゃう
じゃあ悪口言われたら確実に人の気持ちが悪くなりますか？それそうでもないんですね
その人はそのことをそのまま受け取って
別に拒否する気持ちがない場合は怒りが生まれないんです
だから普通に言えば悪口言われたら怒る
それは拒否するんだから
じゃあ拒否するんだから悪口怒るんだよ
じゃあ私はただ耳に入る音に対しては
別に拒否することもなく
受け取ることもなく ただそのまま認識しておきましょうと
すれば 心は心に 怒りの代わりに何もない冷静な平安な気持ちが生まれてくるんです
そういう風に このそれは因果法則なんです
ですから 意識の場合も
このチェタナの場合も
このフリーでもなく フリーでないことでもなく
因縁 因果法則によるものだと理解した方がいいんです
ですから 人間に悪いことをすることも可能であって
いいことをすることも可能なんです
それは自由だからではなくて
悪いことをする原因を抑えるといいことできるようになる
いいことをしたいという心の原因はコントロールしないと悪いことになってしまっちゃう
それだけのこと そこら辺理解してないんだから
神様はすべて創ったんだけど
人間に自由意識も与えているんだとか何とか
ものすごいこの荒っぽい話
概念なんですね すごい丁寧に心のことを考えていってるものじゃないんです
そんなに仏教の立場から申し上げると
そんなに深い高度な概念ではないので
ただごく普通の一般的な考え方だけなんですね
神様に作られたんだと
それで神様はもう全知全能
万能であるとまず信仰してしまって
それでも人間は好き勝手に行動しているんではないかという事実を見る
そこでそちら そこの 2つの正反対の
現象を自分の頭で信じている概念と事実として見える現象を何か合わせて理論付けなくちゃいけない
その時は神様は全知全能でみんな作ったんだけど
同時に人間に自由の意識も与えたんだと
人間がこの自由意識を悪く使っているんだから
世の中に罪があるんだというふうに言ってしまっちゃうんです
ですから そういうのはものすごい高度な知識ではなくて
ごく普通はどんな百姓さんにも考えられるものなんです
そう言ったって なんか百姓さんに何かけなしたことになります
そういう気持ちではなくて
まあどんな人にも考えられるものなんです
それは哲学だと思って
みんなそれによって人生作ってるんだから
まあ悲しいだけ もっと高度な概念に基づいて自分の人生設計すればいいのに
そこでこの何か新しいものをする
したがるのは この意志あるんだからなんです
意志がなければもう全部心もないんです
動かない 行動はない 仏教でカルマというのは業というのはこのチェータナなんです
意志 ですから ある心のこの動きたいというエネルギーについてカルマというんですね
業というんですね ですから
このカルマっていうのは
仏教から言えば正真正銘の心のエネルギーであって
心理的なものなんです
得体知れない形而上学的なものではないんです
ただ理解しにくいだけ
決して形而上学的なものではない
今すでに心にカルマが生まれつつ
生まれない瞬間ないんです
そこでこの心の心を分析すると
まあいくらかの分析がありまして
で それを全部今言いませんだけど
一つはこの行動する心
考える心 喋る心 体を動かす心
行動 何か行動 すごい意志で何かする
その心とその結果からなる心
いわゆる結果の心なんですね
その 2つに分けられるんですね
例えば あの 怒って腹が立って人をぶん殴ると
で それは意志で行動する瞬間
ぶん殴った瞬間から生まれる心は
自分にはどうすることもできないんですね
自然に次にいくらかな心が生まれてしまっちゃうんですね
あるいはぶん殴ると手が痛くなったと
その手が痛くなるのは
まあコントロールできないんですね
それはぶん殴ったことの結果なんですね
結果ですけど 心が痛いという手が痛いということの心ですから
そこにも意志があるんです
その意志と人をぶん殴った意志はもうちょっと違うんですね
違うというのは ぶん殴った時はすごい強い意志で
で ぶん殴るところで手が痛くなったところで
普通の柔らかい柔らかい意志でこの味を味わっている
ですから 一つは原因は作る
もう一つは原因の結果が得る
そこでこちらでカルマというのは自分の強い意志で行動する心の部分だけなんですね
人をぶん殴るところまでカルマであって
ぶん殴ったところで手が痛いところはカルマではなくて
やった行為の結果であると
ですから 結果の心にも意志はあるんだけど
そんなにカルマと言えるほどのものではないんですね
それでこの行動を起こす時の心
いくつかあるんです 例えば悪いことをすると種類 of 心があるんです
貪瞋痴に分けて種類の心が一応決まってあって
その心で人々は悪いことをするんだと
全ての悪いことは そこでいいことをする場合は
また こっちですね 種類の
いい心が心があって それでいいことをするんですね
普通は 悪いことをすると心はありまして
いいことをする場合は種類があります
そういう心でいいこと悪いことしているんだと
それから人々は普通の人はやりませんだけど
この修行したり瞑想したりして
わざわざ自分の心を育てる場合があるんですね
わざわざと心を育てる場合は
禅定とかね 高い境地を得られちゃうんですね
心が高い境地を体験しちゃうんですね
そこら辺の心は アビダンマではつの考えてるんですね
そのつも これは禅定の定ですけどね
禅定は種類あるんだと
それもわざわざ自分でやることだから
これもカルマなんです
そういう風にこの 心がいろいろありまして
そういう心から生まれる識が生まれるんだと
まあそれ あ 色界だけです
なるほど そう これにですね
色界だけですから 禅定の場合はこのつ使わないつだけなんです
25 とか何でなりますかというと
今は説明するともうややこしくなりますから抜けますが
まだそこら辺勉強してないし
まあいわゆる禅定はつありますけど
物質生まれるのはつだけ
それちょっと間違えました
で 不善心はと善心 一般的な欲界の善心はととそちら 20 です
それから禅定の心はつ
そうすると 25 になるんです
そこであの まあそういう心から物質は生まれますよと
ということは 我々の体
我々は考える次第に心が変化するよというぐらいで理解すれば結構です
で 例えば誰かに襲われるようになったと
それで恐怖感が生まれるでしょう
で 恐怖感が生まれてきたら
走れない人も走ってしまっちゃうんですね
で 体が変化するんですね
普通だったらやっぱりもう疲れるんだから走れないんですよとか
ああだこうだ怠けたりとかね
タクシー呼べなくちゃいけないとか
わがまま言ってますけど
もう誰かに襲われるようになっちゃったら
そんなわがまま言ってる場合じゃないんだから
もう走って逃げちゃうんですね
で それは何ですかと その場合はやっぱり体は変化したということなんですね
体力あっても怠けてると体は動かないんですね
重くなっちゃうんです
ですから 意思によって我々の体は瞬間瞬間変化する
だから ごく普通に言えば
怒りやら余計なむさぼりやら無知やら
そういう感情を育てると
それにふさわしい物質が体に生まれる
それで体が悪くなるんですね
こんな健康問題っていうのはものすごいつまらない問題ですけど
人間にはそれしか問題ないんだから
その一生でも一生終わっちゃいますね
その一つの問題だけ 本当にバカバカしいですけど
もうただの物体なのに
そんなこと考えなくていいんですけど
やっぱりそれでもどうせ生まれた時からも欲の話しか頭にない
怒りしか頭にない それでくだらない考え方しか頭に
くだらない本は読んだり
もう全く無知だけで生きてるんですね
そこでまあもう勉強しなくちゃ
商売しなくちゃ 金儲けなくちゃ
あれしなくちゃ これしなくちゃという
もうそれだけ欲だけで
それで次に競争するとかね
ライバル作ったり 戦うとかね
人生はたったそれだけだから
それぐらい元気でいるのは私にとっては不思議なんですね
人間というのは よくも元気でいるなと
貪瞋痴しかないのにと
そこら辺なんですね カルマの立場から言えば
もう人間はもうとんでもなく体が病気で病弱でもなるはずなんですけど
そうでもないんですけど
でももうかなり強烈に病気ということは明確なんですね
ですから 経済的に発展すればするほど
同時に病気という現象も発展していっちゃうんですね
それは科学的な方式には反対でしょ
ちゃんと経済的に発展して
知識があって もう豊かになってくると健康的になるのは当たり前なんですけど
やっぱり逆に食べ物もろくに無く
もう何のことなく生きてる人々は別にそんなお薬飲まなくて何とか生きてるんですからね
昨日テレビでもちょっとニュースステーションで見たんだけど
このある女の人がこのザイールでしたっけね
ルワンダ難民で逃げてる途中で
畑で自分一人で子供を産みましたと
誰も旦那さんが見失った
普通私たちから見ればもう考えられないことなの
全く一人で誰もなく 子供を産めますかと
その子供の面倒をどうやってみるんですかと
でもまあ別に子供は健康ではなかったんだけど
それはお産の問題ではなくて
この難民でしたからね
まあそれでちょっと病気でしたけど
それでもちゃんとやってたんだから
じゃあこの文明人の人がそうなったらどうなるんですかと
どうやって消毒しますか？とか
どうやってお湯はもう探せますか？とか
ああだこうだとかね  [背景音楽]それで何もないんだったらもう心配で死んでしまっちゃうんです
子供のところが まあそういうことで
結局この それはどういうことかで
やっぱり貪瞋痴だけで生きてるんだから
結局健康が優れるんじゃなくて
どんどん悪くなっていっちゃうんです
で それでも それでもなんで元気ですかという次の問題が出てくるんですね
なんで 100%みんな病気じゃなくて
まあ一部だけ病気ですかと
それ次の言葉でそういうこと出てくるんですね
次にはこの 今の言葉 チッタサムッダハナ
次にこの心から物質が生まれるということです
で あの 心から物質が生まれる
心から生まれ 物質が生まれない場合は
このアルーパヴィパーカディパンチャヴィンニャーナという心をいくつか除くんです
アルーパヴィパーカとこっち書いているのは
この皆さん 無色界の禅定の世界なんですね
この禅定の世界で この識のレベルは乗り越えちゃったら
まあ識はない心だけの世界があるんですね
その心だけの世界の その物質に依存しない心を作っちゃったら
その心は物質を作らないんです
それからこのディパンチャヴィンニャーナっていうのはこの眼耳鼻舌身なんです
ただ 目を開けちゃったら見れる
それだけのことです そちらに物質は生まれません
音があると聞こえる それだけのことで特別な物質は生まれません
その眼耳鼻舌身の識だけ
その識と無色界の識で物質は生まれません
他の心から物質は生まれる
で ちょっと説明忘れたところがありまして
前はカルマ 業のことを言ったんですね
業の場合はどんな心が業かというと
このいつでも行動する心は業と言ったんですね
でも業っていうのは この生まれる瞬間の心は業で決めちゃうんですね
例えば人間にここで生まれるでしょ
その生まれる瞬間の心が過去の強い心の結果なんですね
ですから この世で生まれる瞬間でもう業の物質がもう決まっちゃうんですね
そこでその人は死ぬ瞬間まで
その同じ物質は生まれっぱなしなんです
瞬間 瞬間 瞬間 瞬間 だからみんな元気なんです
結局は なぜならば人間で生まれないんで
よっぽどいい業でないと
悪い悪を行ったところで
罪を犯したところで人間に生まれたということはないんです
人間で生まれたということは
もう大変立派な善行ですか
いいカルマ いい業をしたからなんです
それまたいいところで
いい環境で生まれていれば
その分カルマの方が強いということなんですね
豊かな家族で 知識のある落ち着きのある親のところで生まれたら
まあまあそれぐらいカルマがいいということ
それでいいカルマがいいカルマで生まれて
心が生まれる瞬間瞬間カルマが物質を作っているんだから
それがずっと流れていくんですね
その分でなんとか皆様方も他の人々もまあなんとか救われてるんです
人間に生まれたんだから
そのカルマがいいカルマだから
たとえどんな人間に生まれても
あの善行為で生まれるんです
悪を悪いことしちゃったら人間に生まれないんです
そういうことで まあ人間っていうのは
まあ体は一部は健康的なんです
この健康悪くなっちゃうのは
このチッタサムッダハナルーパからなんですね
心からなんです ハンマあって次にチッタなんですね
で ハンマという業はこのもう生まれる瞬間で決まっちゃってますから
ですから どんな人間でもいいカルマでいい業で生まれ
生まれるんです その心が作る物質はいい物質なんです
それでまあ死ぬ瞬間まで
まあいくらか体はある一定の状態で守っ
守られてるんですね  2番目に行くのはチッタサムッタ
心から生まれる物質 これも心からなんですが
カルマも心からなんですけど
こちらははっきりした心からなんです
その場合 我々は現にこの実際に生きている
生きている時 使っている心
喋ったり行動したり考えたりする心
その心からの猛烈な物質が生まれっぱなしなんです
考える